let's say that you can go on a
Generation ship that you and future
Generations will live on in order for us
to get to the closest habitable planet
but by you saying yes to going on it you
commit 20 future generations for the
next half Millennia for being on there
as well is that a choice that you get to
make it gets into long-termism I
recently was reading the book he started
to outlay how many people have lived
versus how many could live in the future
dude we don't matter you start
looking at it and at one point he has
like these 10 human figures and he's
like each one of these 10 is basically a
billion people now I'm gonna take that
same figure and I'm gonna color it in
Black now it's 10 billion people if the
world lasts for 500 million years this
is how many people are still yet to live
in the future and he fills the whole
first page the whole second page the
whole third page and about half of the
fourth page and he goes by the way I'm
just gonna stop now but I could have
filled 20 000 books with these black
little figures because that's how many
people we have yet to go basically the
decisions we make today do have an
impact in the future